in my lifetime I do not believe I've
ever heard a presidential candidate
mention their desire to abolish the
Department of Education the way you have
while I agreed that the educational
system is broken and it surely is please
explain how you plan on abolishing and
overhauling the educational system when
you become president and especially how
long into your presidency would you act
on this plan
so quickly year one because I think that
your ability to get things done
they go down over your time in office
again learning from my predecessors here
this is why I'm going first not with the
legislative agendas because that's
designed to go slowly through Congress
the pinprick in Trump's momentum was
when Congress was asked to repeal and
replace Obamacare Congress didn't want
to do it and then that deflated the
momentum a little bit so I'm not going
to make that mistake I'm going to start
with what the chief executive of this
country can do by running the executive
branch so shutting down the Department
of Education comes early
I'll go quickly on educational reform so
much to say but I'll give you the the
bullets here basic Redux
shut it down that 80 billion dollars
goes to the states to the people to fund
underfunded school choice programs that
allows any parent to decide where they
actually want to send their kids to
school that's in many ways I think the
Civil Rights issue of our time kids
should not be trapped in the zip code
that they're born into now I'm for
school choice on steroids what do I mean
by that
well it turns out that the schools that
spend the most per student those public
schools have the worst achieving results
on a per student basis that's
mind-boggling so I think when a parent
then decides they already have the money
through school choice through the
voucher to move
if that school as in New York City the
bad one's spending forty thousand
dollars per year per student the good
one is twenty thousand or less half the
difference should travel with the kit
ten thousand dollars that goes into that
kid's account invest that according
normal returns
ten thousand per year that's a quarter
million dollar graduation gift for that
kid when he graduates from high school
it's not even close which is a better
use of money that or a teachers
union-laden bureaucracy which by the way
is the number one factor that shackles
public schools that does not shackle
private or Charter Schools is those
teachers unions get rid of the teachers
unions write the contracts in a way that
prevent public teachers unions from
engaging in collective bargaining now
we're talking transparency Choice how do
we get more transparency if you're going
to teach it in the classroom put it on
the internet if you don't want to put it
on the internet you probably shouldn't
be teaching it in the classroom
and then I think there's a room for a
Civic Revival in our education too
and it is my view that
look this is as a first generation
American my parents are immigrants this
is somewhat personal to me
I think that every 18 year old who
graduates from high school
should have to pass
the same Civics test
that every immigrant has to pass in
order to become a naturalized citizen of
this country that's just a good thing
for young people to know something about
our country as that gives you a sense of
how I think of radical educational
reform for a system that's back to being
about the achievement of our students
rather than employment opportunities for
the managerial class thank you I
appreciate that so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
please
foreign